Scientists believe they have an explanation...
...for the mysterious, bare and grassless patches called "fairy circles"...
...that appear regularly throughout the Namib desert in Namibia and South Africa.
And surprise!
It's not fairies.
Biologist Norbert Juergens suggests termites,...
...the only creatures found consistently at the majority of the patches...
...are responsible for the formations.
Study in water content and consistency of the circles' soil,...
...as well as forged plant material under the surface,...
...Juergens concluded that termites consume the roots of the grass within the circle,...
...causing the clearing while letting the grass at the rim survive.
His theory does not, however explain why the patches are circle-shaped,...
...so the theory still has holes as it were.
Furthermore, termites are usually known to enrich soil,...
...making it more hospitable for plants, not less.
So wait, did we officially rule out this fairy thing yet?